[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de 7,8 échos le magazine consacré
à l'actualité économique de notre
territoire et territoires tout de suite
le sommaire bilan immobilier 2010 est
exceptionnel début d'année 2018 déjà
prometteur saint quentin en yvelines va
dévoiler ses atouts lors de la prochaine
édition du mipim 2018 c'est le plus
grand salon à destination des
professionnels de l'immobilier
qu'attend l'agglomération de ce rendez
vous annuel christine turc et de
beauregard directrice attractivité
immobilier d'entreprise à saint quentin
en yvelines sera sur ce plateau un
retour sur l'inauguration du hellen de
nanotech attrape installé au sein du
laboratoire national de métrologie et
d'essai il va permettre de faire
progresser la recherche sur les
nanotechnologies une activité appelée à
jouer un rôle important dans le monde de
demain
enfin dans notre tour d'horizon de
l'actualité économique dans les yvelines
nouveau présenteront un programme pour
les entreprises destinées à renforcer
leur présence à l'international ou
verront également que l'estac a basé à
montigny le bretonneux fait partie des
meilleures écoles d'ingénieurs selon un
récent classement mais tout de suite
ouvrons ce magazine avec un chiffre deux
cent cinquante mille mètres carrés pour
les prochaines années à saint quentin en
yvelines l'immobilier en développement
représentent environ 250 mille mètres
carrés il s'agit de projets neufs
démolis et reconstruits ou bien
restructurées et des projets saint
quentinois qui seront notamment mis en
avant à partir du 13 mars prochain à
l'occasion du mipim à cannes
nous en parlerons en détail dans
quelques minutes avec notre invité
mais avant direction trappe mesurer l
infiniment petit une activité désormais
possible au sein du laboratoire national
de métrologie et d'essai le nouvel
institut hélène nanotech a été inaugurée
la semaine dernière en présence de la
secrétaire d'état delphine génie stéphan
les images sont signées nicolas
kirillovitch voici un microscope à force
atomique métrologique cet outil de
pointe unique en france fait partie des
équipements du nouvel institut ellen
nanotech
intégré au sein du laboratoire national
d'essai et de métrologie
l'institut est en charge de la
réalisation des références à l'échelle
du nanomètre
il a notamment comme objectif de
développer les nanotechnologies vous
avez des applications par exemple sur
les carreaux autonettoyante n'ai plus
besoin de nettoyer vos carreaux vous
avez des textiles qui ne sentent pas
mauvais parce qu'ils sont anti bactérien
vous avez des applications dans la santé
extrêmement importante
par exemple dans le traitement de
certains cancers
depuis plus de dix ans où elle est née
cette équipe de recherche travaillent
sur les nanomatériaux et les nano
dispositif une activité en plein essor
appelé à jouer un rôle important dans le
monde de demain
c'est absolument clé pour l'industrie et
en particulier toute une série
d'industries innovantes dans le domaine
du semiconducteur dans le monde aussi
dans le domaine alimentaire
pharmaceutique puisque les nanomatériaux
sont de plus en plus utilisés dans
l'industrie pour leurs propriétés
particulières une nouvelle technologie
source d'inquiétude d'où l'utilité de ce
nouvel institut sont des particules tout
petit qui peuvent franchir les barrières
biologiques de façon avec des propriétés
tout à fait incroyable et donc il faut
mieux les connaître mieux les
caractérise et c'est ce qu'on va faire
ici
objectif pour l'institut ellen nanotech
devenir un opérateur de référence au
niveau national mais aussi international
à présent nous allons parler immobilier
loyers attractifs taux de vacance faible
les entreprises sont nombreuses un seul
à s'installer sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines l année 2010 est à
d'ailleurs été particulièrement
dynamique
reportage avec un parc de 4,6 millions
de m² d'immobilier d'entreprise saint
quentin en yvelines est le deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien
un rang confirmée par les bons chiffres
de l'année 2010 est on dénombre 104
mouvement et transactions pour un total
de 140 mille mètres carrés d'immobilier
d'entreprise fin 2017 le conseil
départemental des yvelines s'installe
dans l'immeuble alpha à guyancourt
signature également pour la construction
du siège de bmw l'entreprise
assystem se regroupera également en
2019 dans le carré le carré qui est
justement en train de se transformer
situé juste à côté de la gare l'ancien
international est le premier immeuble de
bureaux à avoir été construit à saint
quentin en yvelines
c'était en 1976 on vise une livraison de
la partie bureau enfin l'ensemble des
bureaux dont lé 28 mai 4 bureaux le 1er
avril 2019 date précise et les logements
les 1500 métal logements seront livrés
ça depuis mois plus tard donc on vise
également fin 2019 un projet de
restructuration complète tout comme la
libéro située à guyancourt l'immeuble de
dix mille mètres carrés qui allie
matériaux innovants et naturel sera
livré dans les prochaines semaines le
but ça a été de sortir un petit peu
l'immeuble et de leur est axée sur la
nuit du centre de restructurer
entièrement le bâtiment de créer des de
créer justement des surfaces de
terrasses qui n'avaient pas et voilà il
ya environ vingt mois de travaux sur
cette opération aucune restructuration
saint quentin en yvelines un territoire
que le promoteur immobilier bc france
connaît bien puisqu'il a été également
en charge de la restructuration de
l'immeuble à diagonale à montigny le
bretonneux
les immeubles sont ainsi identifiés on
connaît aussi
les utilisateurs de la zone dont kung fu
partir généralement sur des opérations
en blanc ce qui paraît évident c'est à
dire 100 utilisateurs mais on sait que
c'est un quartier qui est quand même le
deuxième pôle d'île de france et qui est
dynamique donc on a des demandes qui
tourne
de son côté la société j'ai fait que
conçoit et réalise des bâtiments
d'activités des bureaux clés en main
exemples de réalisations sur notre
territoire les entreprises antemeta ya
ce mode et l'attractivité du secteur de
saint quentin en yvelines est
essentiellement dû à la qualité des
entreprises qui sont installés mais
aussi au cadre de vie de saint quentin
en yvelines
la présence notamment de grands
équipements sportifs le vélodrome le
stade de golf avec l'accueil de la
prochaine ryder cup au mois d'octobre
2010 8 font de ce territoire pour nous
une source d'innovation une source
d'inspiration pour réaliser nos projets
immobiliers en lien avec les activités
proposées par le territoire de nombreux
programmes immobiliers qui témoigne de
l'attractivité de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de
l'ancrage des entreprises sur le
territoire et christine turquet de
beauregard m'a rejoint sur ce plateau
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes directrice
attractivité immobilier d'entreprise à
saint quentin en yvelines alors du 13 au
16 mars prochain a lieu à cannes le plus
grand rendez vous des acteurs de
l'immobilier le nid prime pourquoi il
faut y être alors le mipim donc comme
vous le disiez c'est le plus grand salon
international de l'immobilier
d'entreprise et nous avons la chance
d'exposer toujours un pavillon united
grand paris avec 18 autres acteurs
franciliens et nous exposons cette année
pour la première fois avec
l'établissement public paris saclay et
la communauté d'agglo de paris saclay et
nous avons la chance donc de pouvoir
mettre en avant à la fois les grands
projets d'aménagement
l'offre de bureaux l'offre immobilier
d'entreprise comme vous venez de le dire
dans votre reportage et surtout
bénéficiant cette année d'une visibilité
internationale avec à la fois la ryder
cup dont compétition de golf en octobre
mais également
les jeux olympiques et paralympiques en
et cette année en fait le pavillon est
organisée avec un espace central pour
mettre vraiment en valeur cinq
thématiques qui sont justement les
grands événements internationaux
l'offre immobilière l'innovation les
transports et les concours
architecturaux alors quel est le
programme ce qu'il va y avoir des temps
forts pendant pendant ces quatre jours
tout à fait alors nous avons donc dans
cet espace central nous avons une carte
interactive qui va présenter à la fois
les projets d'aménagement l'offre de
bureaux les événements donc ryder cup et
jeux olympiques et sur notre stand nous
avons nous allons inaugurer un
hologramme pour mettre en avant cinq
projets immobiliers qui sont le newton
le proxima 5 le carré l'alb héros n'ont
pas là le beru pardon le swing et le
seven et comme temps fort donc nous
allons avoir bien sûr des conférences
mais nous avons également organisé par
par paris région entreprises des flirts
hausse donc ce sont des visites
thématiques qui sont vraiment conçu pour
des groupes très restreint
d'investisseurs internationaux et qui
vont venir sur notre stand et on aura
quelques minutes pour présenter à la
fois notre offre immobilière nos projets
d'aménagement mais également les jeux
olympiques à ce que des nouveaux projets
vont être vont être annoncées justement
l'occasion de ce meeting alors se font
pas vraiment enfin oui il ya bien sûr
des nouveaux projets comme le newton par
exemple où le proxima 5 mais c'est
surtout la mise en valeur de 2 des
projets la mise en valeur également de
tout l'écosystème de
saint quentinois de l'immobilier
d'entreprise pour mettre en avant nos
ambassadeurs et surtout vendre notre
territoire auprès des investisseurs et
des utilisateurs internationaux
c'est vraiment la finalité l'objectif
premier de ce salon justement c'était ma
dernière question concrètement vous
attendez quoi de ce rendez-vous de ce
rendez vous annuel mais de faire venir
justement à la fois des investisseurs
internationaux mais également des
entreprises utilisatrices pour remplir
les bureaux mais c'est surtout de
continuer à valoriser notre territoire
et il n'y a que sur ce salon que l'on
peut vraiment intervenir auprès des
investisseurs et des utilisateurs
internationaux
merci christine turquie et de beauregard
d'avoir répondu à l'invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes la directrice
attractivité et immobilier d'entreprise
à saint quentin en yvelines des
entreprises yvelinoise primés lors du
dernier salon international de
l'agriculture l estaca reconnue comme
l'une des meilleures écoles d'ingénieurs
et un programme qui permet aux
entreprises de booster leurs
exportations c'est tout de suite dans
l'écho en bref ateliers collectifs et
accompagnement sur mesure pour renforcer
sa présence à l'international
c'est ce que propose le dispositif
booster paris saclay export présenté au
ski cubes à partir du mois d'avril ces
entreprises des yvelines et de l'essonne
vont pouvoir bénéficier de ce programme
pendant 18 mois
ces entreprises doivent être
exportatrice nous avoir un fort projet
développement l'export parce que
l'objectif c'est partager les
expériences dont peu convient pas
seulement pour prendre on vient dans ce
groupe pour donner partager les bons
tuyaux les bons contacts les bonnes
adresses
les bonnes façons de faire lorsqu'on
veut se développer à l'international
l'estac a distingué lors d'un récent
classement l'usiné nouvelle a publié le
palmarès des 100 meilleures écoles
d'ingénieurs
le magazine consacré au monde industriel
s'est basé sur les données publiées par
la commission des titres d'ingénieurs
ainsi que sur l'insertion des diplômés
dans la vie professionnelle avec note
globale de 49,60 l'école implantée à
montigny le bretonneux et 8e le
département des yvelines bien présent
lors de l'édition 2018 au salon
international de l'agriculture
avec près de 1000 exploitations
agricoles les yvelines sont le deuxième
territoire agricole d'île de
france lors du concours général agricole
cinq entreprises ont été distinguées
parmi elles les yaourts et grecs ont
obtenu deux médailles d'argent
cette start up basée à bouafles fabrique
ses productions avec du lait de la ferme
de grignon la ferme installée à
thiverval grignon a de son côté décroché
une médaille de bronze pour sa crème
dessert au chocolat
avant de se quitter on va voir ensemble
les rendez vous économiques qui vous
attendent
le mardi 13 mars de 14 heures à 16
heures un atelier micro-entreprises
lancer votre activité est organisée au
ski cube à guyancourt
c'est gratuit mais il faut s'inscrire au
numéro qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran au 01 39 30 51 30
et puis si vous êtes une entreprise que
vous avez vu des besoins de recruter et
bien le jeudi 29 mars de 10 heures à 22
heures aura lieu en piste pour l'emploi
ce sera au vélodrome nationale
inscriptions sur www.skype.com r voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve le mardi et
20 mars pour un nouveau et 7,8 échos à
très bientôt
[Musique]